[Music]
you have a fascinating background your
mom's a model and your dad is this radio
icon shadow Stephens who I've listened
to all the time like I feel like I grew
up with shadows yeah yeah that's my dad
don't we look alike yeah exactly I'm
just curious I've heard his voice so
often he must must be strange to hear
your dad all the time talking in the
background oh yeah as you go through
life I mean he's just had so much
success with his voiceover career and
radio and everything it's kind of like
everywhere I went there he was like I
remember one time I went to raging
waters with my friends I was in high
school or something and I'm just hanging
out by the wave pool or something and
and I hear my dad's voice come on on the
radio loudspeaker thing and it's he's
doing some sort of other gig or
something it's like everywhere I go
there's my dad's voice if you have
diarrhea don't use the water now you are
in amazing shape I'm told that you're
sort of a workout fanatic and that you
take is this true you take Richard
Simmons workout class I have yes okay
well there he is I think there he is
pinned up against the edge
well I have a question and I don't mean
to I'm not a mean guy but the guy never
looks to be in shape to me no I'm trying
to just say this the nicest way Andy
please back me up
I'm not look at me Who am I what I'm
saying is he looks like he's constantly
burning calories and then he wears these
short shorts in a tank top and he
doesn't look like there's any tone there
he's got it he's got it going on okay
for like in his late 90s for his 90s he
looks fantastic it's the best 98 year
old man I've ever seen yeah so what does
he like when you take a workout class
with him is it a tough workout or is he
just yelling and sort of joke actually
it is a tough workout like he works you
out for like an hour and a half but it's
the weirdest experience it's the
weirdest experience why what is ideal
right well every single class is themed
so my first class was a Broadway themed
class and everyone in the class is like
at least 80 years old and and they come
in full costume and there's old ladies
and like and like top hats and like
glittered gloves and but the first song
that came on when we started that class
was doe a deer from The Sound of Music
and he just runs around the class
licking your arm and spitting and
non-serious you're making a police
report what do you mean he runs around
licking people oh you're not allowed to
do that he's not allowed to do that he's
Richard Simmons Stone you can't say no
or he'll spit on you that's the nicest
thing I've ever heard anybody say about
a workout class you can't say no to
Richards no it doesn't sound fun at all
I'm never going to that class no no no
no I will not go to that class I will go
to the class with the authorities
I guess got that sounds crazy to me if
there were a reason why he's looking
people or is it I think it's just like
whatever inspires him in the moment I
mean he just feels like he's just got to
get up on yeah yeah the sweat maybe
turns him on I don't know okay
okay well I don't think you've helped
him here tonight I promise you guys it's
a really really great class you gotta go
like you go in costumes and what other
workout class can you do that no no it
sounds stressful
you